You know, when I saw this for the first time I was just like how did--did--I don't...
It's really about doing it a hundred times and you're gonna get one of them right.
Oh my god--and its a loop
Thanks to LG TV for sponsoring this video. Stick around to the end to find out more
Hi, welcome back to another episode of VFX artists react. Today, we are joined by the one only Zach king
What's up, Zach and his team are known for doing a very unique style of visual magic and visual trickery
It's very hard to figure out how Zach does it
I'm excited for this episode because I really want to see if you guys can break down how the magic is done
Well should we jump in? Let's do it. All right
Woah
Trippy
Ya, just send me that email, I'm just going to step in-
Oh
ah ya
Are you kidding me?
That loony tunes
Oh woah
It says wet paint...
Oh and it's a loop
Oh my god
and its a loop!
Wow, that's great. We wanted to reward those who watch it for a third time
Oh sorry, sir, it's trying you should put a sign up or something
Oh
Tricky, wow
Dude I was going to be like man that extra 10% you put at the end--  but you took it another 10%
So, where do you think the loop point is in this? I have a wild idea. Mmhmm?
It's not actually looping. Until the very end, because you actually built a set that has like three
identical corridors-- I love that answer
We talked about that-- really? We were gonna do that at some point
because you could have made it a square-- yah-- and gone over and over-- but no it's-- So it's not that oh no... one sensible spots for
The loop point to be, would be when Luke wipes you. So that shrug to painting is the beginning
And he wipes across you is when you'd wipe back to the beginning. Yep, you've got it. This stuff is so good
Oh, I know this one. I've seen this one too. Look at that commitment to time.
We came up with this idea like the night before the Eclipse. That's-- that's really well done.
Did you guys wait up there all night, or did you come back later on? We came back
I think we shot that. I like 4:00 p.m. Or 5:00 p.m. And then came back at 8 or 9. So for this shot
There's no Sun actually there, right? The sun's coming from a different angle. Right, if you look at the Sun source, it's off to
the right there
But it works because you guys are to the left of the the Sun that you have on the frame
This one is really simple
It's it's a straight jump cut but there are things you have to think about like hey if we come back
Later at night. Like how are you to know the spot?
So we're literally like taking sticks and drawing
you know in the sand I take my shoes of your
Camera screen you simply got to make sure your hands are in the exact same spot. Yeah, it's just guesswork
It's really about doing it a hundred times and you're gonna get one of them, right?
so obviously
I'm not the first person to come up with jump cuts and one my favorite material to reference is Charlie Chaplin and Buster Keaton
Well, these guys were doing jump cuts when it was like actually really hard to do like they'd have to go through you know
The frames and find the right one and they didn't get to like play with it
It was like once they cut it was pretty much it's like nudge it three frames to the right
Yeah, but there's like oh, let me get my glue
So if somebody wanted to execute a perfect match cut, what tips would you have for them?
It really is a practice thing but have some your body hold the camera go to a a
Position and stand still have a person do the change
Like let's say it's changing the shirt and then you litter is it this basic you freeze go change your shirt
Come back go in the position, but it's getting back to that position
Like we have a little overkill techniques where people will come in and hold each major joint of my body
You know if your chest moves like that's a big visual difference
Especially your head too like that needs to be in the same spot
So it's literally like it's kind of awkward, but people will come up and just kind of feel that they're hugging you
And you like wiggle out of the position really go to the bathroom
change really quick come back wiggle in and then they line you back up Wow, so it's basic but it's also
overkill and complex
Okay, so this one legitimately when I saw this for the first time I was just like, how do I
Want to take a guess at how you did this so there you actually have
To guess I don't know. Okay, so I'm guessing that there is no ladder
it's just projection mapping and it's really really well done projection mapping projection mapping requires you to
Have a 3d track of your scene as well as someone basic 3d reconstruction in this scene
You have a very basic plane in another plane. So your projection ends up being really simple
Yeah
and right as the camera kind of like pulls back and then locks into place right here someone flies in a ladder and you just
Place so casually and stand upon it and then right there the ladders gone
Someone's ready to pull the ladder off screen the moment. You're off the interesting theory
So here's what I'll tell you about this one. This one holds a special place in my heart
So I'm not gonna tell you how it was done because I also want people to guess in the comments for this one
Oh, yeah, this one has a lot of different theories on how it was done
But I will say that there was real paint on set
Okay
The parts about these videos that are really fun to me is like how everything is put there so quickly
It's just really about timing. And again, this is one of the videos that we have to do
75 times just to get Wow that many takes your yard Zack leave a comment down below with your guests
Let us know how you think it was done. Was that do you consider yourself?
A magician a magician a well I dabble in the weekends. No and like I grew up doing magic
I loved magic
I too
Have been known to do the reason I don't like being called a magician is cuz I feel like it offends actual magicians
Yes, because I haven't put in the work to earn that title and they've literally practice
You know sleight of hand or whatever stage tricks for years
I out of respect for that. I'm not but I can see why people visually call it magic. I think it made
That's me and some of the art team sitting up all night just just you know acrylic paint on my clothes
It's a YouTube thumbnail
The genius and a piece of work like this is that once again the digital effects are very straightforward
I mean, you're basically just taking a freeze-frame from right there
Yeah, and just tracking it back onto the frame, right?
You know from going backwards in the video then likewise at the end and that's it for like the digital effect
yeah, you know it's just really said we're cutting holes in flats and
Putting up the picture frames. I know it pays off
Like if you do it practically always looks better like a lot of people could just throw up a green screen
But it has little like there's a look to that
I love the reveal of the parallax because as the camera moves at first like the background moves at the same rate as you
But the moment you start moving now the background is moving like slower
Yeah, I call that the extra like 15 percent extra 10 percent. We'll ask ourselves at the very end like okay
Is there anything that's an extra ten percent that we can do here?
Maybe it's okay the camera move or where's it in the story where you need an extra little beat? Yeah
There's like little details too that are fun. Like a museum would actually still have the electrical circuits. It doesn't like that
We'd print those are just like printouts, you know, like cutting out just a paper. Oh, that's so smart
Whoa, okay
Would you look at that five o'clock Wow, it really does fly
Well, we're going with a lot of work to do I need this done by the end of the day
Taking that extra step. I think that's really what makes you stand out. What's your guess for this one?
So I think you have a hole in the wall
You have actual post-it notes glued to the wall there and there's just like a little like doggy door flap
But someone else's hand is coming through same thing with all your desk there
We have one other guy in the office who works on her team who happens to have the exact same looking hand as me
So but you'll notice I think he doesn't have a ring on that's the only thing he more picked up on
It's really a matter of me and him just knowing without him looking the timing and so with that same take of the hands working
It also had the perf the paper had to like he had this big stack of papers
Papers that he was chucking through the hole that most times were getting caught
How many takes did you could take you guys to is maybe like 35 or 40?
I don't work on this one
But it was really just practicing the hand bit and once we got that timing I had no idea you guys
worked so hard
To get so many takes and just nail it but in a way like everything is so perfect at the end for these short clips
That it makes sense. So the guy that's filled coffee on himself so notice yet
We have little Easter eggs running throughout our videos all of them. There's like a back line story happening when there's extras
There was a Starbucks video that we did. It was a fake Starbucks Coffee app
We could pull the coffee out of the phone and he's driving and he tries to send it back through because he wants a different
Coffee but it sprays all over him. So this is his probably this actually is part three
There's a part when he's going to the office in traffic
Someday you'll be able to take all of his videos put them in order and see his little mini movie. I love that
So I know we're not exactly reacting to Hollywood movies today. But there's a lot of other great visual Wizards out there
So if there's anybody else you would like us to get on the show or react to their work
Please leave a comment down below. It's great inspiration helps guide us what we should do in our future episodes
Well, that was smooth
That was super smooth. It's it's one thing to be able to like drop through the the shelf like that
like that's not super hard to do, but the fact that the guy comes busting in like
Literally a half second after you disappear. Yeah merging that's the two things together
I would assume the bottom the drawers just cut out. You're dropping through it
But then you'd have to paint yourself out and it's one thing to paint yourself out
But when there's people behind you running through the door
You have to rebuild them and they're lighting in their shadow. And that's where it gets crazy
So did you rebuild all that area underneath there?
Yeah, we had to and I just I almost don't believe that you had you paid yourself out though
Because you have to add the flashlight the shadows the foot
So we're the guys bust them through the same shot as you drop it in through the the drawer
That is the question. That is the long day in question. I am gonna hazard a guess that it is actually two different takes
Oh wait prints spotted it because I feel like it can sense a little bit that red wedge on the top of your hair
What roto edge?
You might have gotten me on that one
So the hard one in this one is it actually loops
Like if you're perfectly so to do that you basically to start here wake up grab chair throw go back to sleep
Camera goes in and then everyone's like pause. So that's that's the loop point right there. Oh, I love that
So planar tracking is when you track basically anything onto a flat surface
You'll see a lot of movies on the tracking screens
This would be a normal planar track except for the fact that the cardboard walls. Yeah
So what would be a simple effect something becomes complicated
Because the cardboard starts distorting and that planar track is no longer a plane. This is a manual art
Someone had to go in and then morph the image to kind of follow this cardboard cutout
I'd also imagine that this cardboard cutout has the graphics on it as well. And you're kind of blending between the two
Dude this is a long line. Have you guys been to Randy's Donuts?
I've never been just seen it in so many movies, but I've never even seen it in person. The line is long
I mean that's what this concept is about
We we go to show a show up in film and the lines long and so we added that to the concepts in the beginning
That's plastic let's get a real one
Fun little easter egg. It says Randy's and that's there
I'm going to guess that that's a 3d model the entire time. Dang. I give up
I'm holding something that we had to you know, put the donut there onto it
I love the subtle touch of the roof of the building caving in. Yeah getting little bit like physics simulations in there
So another question for you, once again, really subtle the people that are reacting in the audience are those green screen didn't elements
You were the first person to notice that so those two guys in
The picture Clinton that thing just hopping around climbing up the wall
And you guys really
Remember the scene in Inception that's rotating. We basically had a mini version of that built the rotating room, you know
You've got the room here and the camera and the key is getting the camera to lock on
You have all this rigging to make sure that doesn't move and so that you get the illusion
You know with the room perspective not changing the way I really wanted to have the people in there was to harness them in
But we had a couple issues one insurance and safety but also like their face within five seconds for a super red
It's off-putting you're watching and their cheeks kind of like often they gain weight
So you shoot one giant plate of all your actors
they're going through all the motions and reacting to you and then a separate plate where
You are in the costume and you do the whole move around the everything is down
I assume those curtains those are moving in the scene. So those curtains are glued like you cannot move them
They're like completely hard. Okay, those little details. Yeah, everything is come like glued eighty times
Do you miss your passion for practical effects? I love him. That's like all my favorite movies
I love the matte paintings. They were doing you know, you have a scene of Charlie Chaplin on
Rollerblades like barely going down this harrowing fall and it was really just up close
They had an image
Literally printed were painted oftentimes
Close to the camera as your background plate and you look at like the perfect mix in in
Jurassic Park like because they had most of close-up shots with the dinosaur that was real like it sells everything else
I don't know if I would love showing up to
Jurassic world set now cuz it's like you're looking at people in suits like it doesn't have the same magic
Yeah, and I think it affects the final product. Oh, definitely Zak
Thank you for indulging us as we try to guess and reveal the secrets you guys did. Well, yeah
Well, I feel like I didn't get anything. I want to know their guesses, right I do too
I want to know other videos what you guys think how it was done now that they've got some insights
Yeah, you guys have good guesses. Oh, I'm proud. Okay. Thank you. All right
So go to your Zak's channel consider subscribing if you haven't already you can't wait to see you guys in the next video
Hey guys, we're gonna give you the chillest brand integration we've ever seen because Jake is really busy right now
So that's on our shoulders. All right, Clint play me a tune if it's not the pros through it
We're gonna talk about the new LG nano cell TV, which is a new TV. We got in the office
We're playing Smash Brothers on it every evening which you know, that means no latency vibrant colors and big enough picture, too
Well all of us and see our characters and lifelike size
So LG. Nano sale TVs have a new technology in them. Nano technology, I guess
nano cell technology
It's a multitude of things from a very thin and nano bezel to nano filters that give you more vibrant colors in the pixels
Long story short before the price. This is one of the best images at a television
I have ever seen I'm telling you this not because it's a marketing point. In fact, that's not even on this paper
I'm telling you this other personal experience. I see a lot of images. Hey, I'm a visual effects artist. I
Appreciate beautiful imagery and this TV is actually nice
I have an old vizio at my place and I can literally see like the LED like cross work behind it
I've been think about upgrading and no lie
I'm probably gonna get an LG nano cell because I've been super impressed with how good the images at how good the price is
So if you are in the market for a new TV go check it out. You will not be disappointed
It has our endorsement. We are loving in here at the office
It's true. It's true. It's true
Just watch and tell me if you guys notice something weird, I
Tell you guys say anything weird
You see it. Are we looking at the fire? It's hard to catch catch. What is there a flicker?
You can say that we're getting some frame frame duplications as you're going free, my friend